それでは、「週刊Life is beautiful　二千二十六年九月二十二日号」をお送りします。
こんしゅうのざっくばらんな話題です。
まずは、新しいタイプのエーアイ、JEVについてお話しします。
Typesafeエーアイというベンチャー企業から、新しいタイプのエーアイが公開されて、業界ではかなり大きな話題になっているんですよね。
ChatGPTやClaude、Geminiなどのエーアイモデルは、入力された質問に対して、一トークンずつ生成して返すタイプのエーアイで、「大規模言語モデル」、つまりエルエルエムと呼ばれています。
今回紹介する新しいエーアイ、「JEV」は、構造化された質問に対して確率で答える“判断モデル”とでも言うべきエーアイなんです。
たとえば、受け取ったメールがフィッシング詐欺かどうかを判断させたい場合、メールの内容に加えて、次のような構造化されたフォーマットで質問を投げます（実際にはJSON形式です）。
「phishing_mail:
type: noul
instructions: このメールはフィッシング詐欺か？
」
これに対する返事は、「phishing_mail:
noul: 0.87」といった感じで、確率で返してきます。
「noul」は「no」と「null」を組み合わせた造語で、「はい／いいえで答えられる主張」を表す型なんですね。
エルエルエムも、同じような判断をしているように見えますが、実際には一トークンずつ確率を考えながら文字列を生成していくだけなので、一度ある方向に向けた文章を書き始めると、その方向性に流れて書き続けてしまう傾向があるんです。
そのせいで、たまに間違ったことを堂々と主張してしまう、いわゆるハルシネーションが起きてしまうことがあります。
これって、一トークンごとに行う確率計算が積み重なっていくことで、結果的に大きなノイズになってしまうんですよ。
一方で、判断モデルはエルエルエムと違い、構造化された質問に対して確率で答えるだけなので、判断が難しい場合にはそのことがはっきり分かるし、エルエルエムみたいにハルシネーションを起こす可能性がない、というのが大きな特徴です。
ただし、もちろん出てきた確率自体が間違っているということも十分にあり得るので、注意は必要なんですよね。
試しに、TeslaのCybercabについての報道をまとめた文章を渡して、「オーナーが年三万ドル稼げるという主張は現実的か」と聞いてみたんです。
すると返事は「十五パーセント」と返ってきました。
「規制当局はCybercabの自己認証を認めるか、免除の枠に収めるか、販売を止めるか」と聞けば、「免除：七十六パーセント、停止：十八パーセント、認める：二パーセント」と、分布で返してきました。
そして、何よりも興味深いのがそのコストです。
入力に関しては、百万トークンあたり四セント、出力は無料です。
オープンエーアイの最新モデル、ジーピーティー-6 Astraだと、入力は百万トークンあたり十ドル、出力は五十ドル、もっとも低価格のジーピーティー-5.6 Lunaでさえも、入力は二十セント、出力は一ドル二十セントと、やっぱり桁違いに安いんです。
スピードもものすごく速くて、playground、つまりブラウザ上のお試し画面で試す限り、一瞬、だいたい零点一秒から零点二秒で答えが返ってきます。
開発者自身が、これを「System One」、つまり直感的で自動的、無意識に働く人間の思考モード（ダニエル・カーネマンの用語ですね）と呼んでいるのも納得です。
深く考えるのではなくて、本当に直感的に答えを出している感触があります。
入出力がどちらも構造化されているので、自然言語で会話ができるエルエルエムと比べるとどうしても不便ですが、そこをエルエルエムを間に挟んで、「高速でハルシネーションを起こさない判断モデル」として使うのは十分ありだと感じています。
JEVはオープンウェイトのモデルではないので、使える範囲は限られているんですが、JEVに刺激を受けたオープンウェイトのモデルが出てくれば、大量で高速な判断が必要な場面で、かなり広く活用されるだろうなと思っています。
ここからは、エーアイが働いている隙にできる片足スクワットについてです。
ずっと座って仕事をしていると、つい運動不足になってしまいます。
そこで、エーアイに仕事を任せている合間に簡単にできる運動がないかなと探していたところ、たどり着いたのが「片足スクワット」です。
片足に全体重がかかるので、普通の両足スクワットよりも少ない回数で同じ負荷をかけることができて、だいたい片足ずつ十五回程度で、短時間・効率よく運動ができます。
同じ片足スクワットでも色々なスタイルがあるので図を参考にしてください。
筋力が強い人は、片足を浮かせてやったりするみたいですが、私には無理ですね。
どんなやり方でも、つま先に向かって深く沈み込むと膝に負担がかかるので、かかとに体重をかけて沈み込むのがコツです。
続いて、エーアイの危険性についてです。
ついこの間、オープンエーアイとアンソロピックの両社で研究してきたアンソロピックの研究者、Jacob Coxonさんが、「両社は自己改善する超知能に向かって一直線に走っていて、私たちは自分の命をかけている」と述べ、会社が安全よりも競争に勝つことを最優先していると批判して退社し、話題になりました。
参考までに、
[EN]Anthropic safety researcher resigned with a warning about AI[/EN]
の記事があります。
その流れを受けて、今度はグーグル DeepMindの研究者、Bilal Chughtaiさんも同様の警告をして退社しました。
こちらも参考として、
[EN]I recently resigned from Google DeepMind, where I worked on AGI safety and alignment research[/EN]
という記事があります。
いっぱんの人には何が起きているのか分かりづらいと思いますが、多くの人は「エーアイが人類を滅ぼすなんてことはない」と感じているのかなと思います。
将来のことを予測するのは簡単なことではないので、ここでいったん現状を整理してみます。
いま最先端のエーアイの知能や知識は、博士課程の学生と同じくらいのレベルにまで達していて、オープンエーアイやエヌビディアは「AGI」、つまり汎用人工知能を達成したと言い始めています。
エーアイ企業は、ASI、つまりあらゆる分野で人間をはるかに超える超知能を誰よりも先に作ろうと競争しており、そのために、RSI、いわゆるエーアイ自身がエーアイを改良する手法、「Recursive Self-Improvement」を導入し始めています。
研究者たちは、「数年以内にASIが達成できる」と予想しています。
そして、その超知能が人間の望み通りに動く保証はなく、もし制御を離れてしまえば、人類の永久的な無力化や死をもたらすリスクがあると、多くの研究者が感じているのです。
そのリスクには様々なものがありますが、いちばん分かりやすいのは、悪意を持った人がエーアイを利用してサイバー攻撃や生物兵器の製造などを行ってしまう可能性です。
特に生物兵器の場合、わずかなコストで人類全体に大きな悪影響を与えてしまうリスクがあるのが問題になっています。
今回アンソロピックとグーグルを辞めた二人は、こういったリスクがあるのに会社は利益、つまりASIを一番最初に作ることを優先し、人類全体を大きなリスクにさらしていると批判しているわけです。
「そんなにリスクがあるなら法律で規制すればいいじゃないか」と考える人もいると思いますが、そう簡単な話ではありません。
規制が強すぎると、イノベーションの妨げになってしまいますし、安全保障の観点から、米国だけ、あるいは西側だけで規制したとしても、中国に「エーアイ覇権」を許してしまうことになるかもしれません。
さすがに無視できなくなった結果として、アンソロピックのDario Amodeiさんが、「フロンティア・モデルの開発スピードを落とすこと」を提案し、
[EN]We Must Pace the Frontier[/EN]
という論考を発表しています。
それに対しオープンエーアイのSam Altmanさんが賛同し、さらにグーグルのDemis Hassabisさんも、具体的な自主規制の枠組みを提案しています。
その中身は、
[EN]A Framework for Frontier AI and the Dawning of a New Age[/EN]
という記事で述べられています。
Bloombergの記事
[EN]OpenAI Says It’s Working With Anthropic, Google on AI Safety[/EN]
によると、三社の間ではすでに協議が始まっているようです。
もちろん、政府による規制よりも自主規制のほうが、これらの企業にとっては都合がいいのは間違いないですが、中国の企業が参加しない状態で規制をかけても、本質的に効果があるのかは正直かなり疑問ですよね。
それに加えて、中国のエーアイモデルの多くはオープンウェイトなモデルで、ファインチューニング、つまり微調整も簡単なため、元のモデルに危険な質問には答えない仕組みが入っていたとしても、ファインチューニングでそれを外すことができてしまい、その危険性を回避する方法はありません。
不安を煽るような話になってしまいましたが、これが今の現状で、リスクは本物です。
ただ、リスクばっかり気にしていても仕方がないので、必要なアンテナは張りつつも、エーアイがもたらす豊かな社会に向けて自分にできることをやっていくしかないなと考えています。
ここからは、ジーピーティー-6 Astraについてご紹介します。
せんしゅうも紹介したジーピーティー-6 Astraの三ディーモデル生成能力があまりにも高いので、ついにオープンエーアイのProプラン（月額百ドル）に加入してしまいました。
もしコーディングにも使えれば、アンソロピックのプランを「Max20」（月額二百ドル）から「Max5」（月額百ドル）に減らせるかもしれない、という期待もあります。
せっかくなので、Astraで作った三ディーモデルをシェアするサービス、「Shape Gallery」を作ってみました。
そこに、Xで募集したお題の三ディーモデルを作成して投稿したんです。
Astraへの指示の出し方によっては、とても精密な三ディーモデルが作れるという手応えがあります。
まず、厳島神社についてです。
この場合、文化庁が公開している詳細配置図を活用して、正確な配置のモデルを作っています。
従来はこうした作業を人手でおこなっていたため、数十万円から数百万円もかかっていたんですが、Astraを使うと、わずか10分程度、エーピーアイの利用料でいえば数十円くらいでできてしまうんです。
期待を大きく上回ったのが、Breguetの懐中時計、No.1160です。
部品表をインターネットで見つけて、そのギアの歯の数まで正確にモデル化してくれました。
これも、人がやろうとすれば気が遠くなるほど手間がかかる作業ですが、Astraに頼むとあっという間に終わってしまうんです。
続いて、フロンティア・ラボのビジネスモデルについてです。
ここでいう「フロンティア・ラボ」とは、最先端のエーアイモデル、つまりフロンティアモデルを開発している研究所のことを指します。
代表的なのは、オープンエーアイやアンソロピックです。
彼らの特徴としては、開発したモデルをエーアイサービスとして提供することを、主なビジネスモデルにしている点にあります。
もちろん、最先端のエーアイモデルを開発しているという意味では、グーグルやメタ、それからxAI（SpaceXの一部）もそうですが、これらは他に収益源があるため、会社全体を「フロンティア・ラボ」と呼ぶことはありません。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックのように、他の収益源を持たない純粋な「フロンティア・ラボ」のビジネスの収益構造は、ざっくり分けるとこうなっています。
まず、売上は「エーアイサービス（月額課金および従量課金）」です。
経費としては「人件費」、「学習コスト」、そして「推論コスト」がかかってきます。
従来型のソフトウェア・ビジネスと決定的に違うのは、学習や推論の際に必要なエーアイデータセンターへの投資額がとても大きいことなんです。
たとえば1ギガワット、大型原発一基分の電力を使うデータセンターですと、おおよそ百億ドル、つまり一兆六千億円ものお金が必要となります。
この中には電気代も含まれています。
仮に、この計算能力のうち50パーセントを新しいエーアイモデルの学習用に、もう半分の50パーセントをエーアイサービス提供の推論用に使い、エーアイサービスからの売上が二百五十億ドルだとしましょう。
すると、売上や粗利率は以下の通りとなります。
なおこれは、年間ではなくエーアイデータセンターを運営する全期間での値です。
・売上：二百五十億ドル
・売上原価：五十億ドル
・粗利：二百億ドル
・粗利率：80パーセント
・研究開発費：五十億ドル＋人件費
こんな大きなきぼのビジネスだからこそ、トップクラスのエーアイ研究者に対して100万ドル、約一億六千万円以上の給料を支払う価値があるんです。
エーアイ研究者は、とにかくお金を惜しみなく使って、試行錯誤で次世代エーアイモデルをかいはつする必要があり、会社の運命は彼らの手腕に大きくかかっています。
最近は価格競争によってトークンあたりの価格は下がり続けているものの、一方でトークンの使用量も爆発的に増え、さらに電力あたりに生成できるトークンの量も増えているため、利益は十分に上がっていると見られています。
当然ですが、同じ電力からより多くのトークンが生み出せるようになれば、売上は増えて粗利率もアップします。
そこで、推論向けに最適化された専用チップ、いわゆるASIC（エーエスアイシー）が非常に注目されているわけです。
こうして見ると、フロンティア・ラボというのは「ソフトウェア会社」というより、巨額のせつびとうしを前提に高い粗利率を狙う「発電所」や「半導体工場」に近いビジネスになっています。
データセンターさえ作ってしまえば粗利率が80パーセントというモデルは、投資家にとって非常に魅力的で、だからこそリスクを承知の上で巨額の資金が集まり続けている、という構図なんですね。
ここで参考資料についても触れておきます。
[EN]Rittenhouse Research on X: Anthropic's compute capacity is split between training and inference[/EN]
続いて、私の目に留まった記事についてご紹介します。
[EN]Introducing the DeepMind Institute[/EN]
グーグル DeepMindが、AGI、つまり汎用人工知能、人間の脳が持っているようなあらゆる認知能力を備えたエーアイの時代に向けて、社会が答えを出すべき課題について議論するための研究組織、「DeepMind Institute（DMI）」を立ち上げた、という共同創業者Shane Leggさんによる発表です。
上の「エーアイの危険性」でも触れましたが、エーアイの危険性や社会へのインパクトへの注目が高まっている中で、グーグルとしても受け身ではなく、自ら積極的にこの問題に取り組もうという姿勢だと見て良いかなと思います。
DMIが取り組むテーマとしてあげているのは、たとえばこういった問いです。
私たちは何に価値を置き、AGIは「人間であること」の意味をどう変えるのか。
AGIシステムや、それが形成するエージェント、これは自律的に行動するエーアイですが、その集団をいかに安全に構築し、統治するか。
社会のどの制度や政策をAGIに合わせて適応させるか、あるいは根本から作り直す必要があるのか。
DMIはグーグル内部の研究者だけでなく、外部の研究者や思想家にも発表の場を開放したいということなので、シンギュラリティ・ソサエティとしても、なにか協力できることがないか考えてみたいと思います。
次の記事です。
[EN]Apple Explores Enterprise AI Servers, Holding Talks With Nvidia Over NVLink Technology[/EN]
アップルがエンタープライズ市場向けに自社製チップ、たとえばM8 Ultraを搭載したエーアイサーバーを開発しており、その際、エヌビディアのチップ間を接続する技術「NVLink Fusion」の導入も検討しているという、The Information（有料）の報道を伝えるXでの投稿です。
アップルがエーアイサーバー市場に参入するのは意外にも思えますが、新しくシーイーオーになったJohn Ternusさんがハードウェア畑の人であることを考えると、まったく否定できる話でもないのかもしれません。
アップルは以前から、自社独自チップを搭載したエーアイサーバーの構築を進めており、iPhoneやiPad向けインテリジェンスのバックエンドとして利用することを宣言していましたが、いまだにSiriはChatGPTとくらべて大きく見劣りしており、そこだけ見ると、成功しているとは言いがたいのが現状です。
しかし、SpaceXやxAIがエーアイサーバーの計算能力を外部販売して大きな利益を上げ、かつ同時に推論向けに最適化されたASICが次々と開発されている現状を見ると、勝負がアップルの得意とする「1ワットあたりの計算量」で決まる場合、アップルにも十分な勝ち目があると言えるのかもしれません。
続いてこちらです。
[EN]RelateAnything: Real-Time Open-Vocabulary Relation Prediction From Any Inputs[/EN]
画像の中の物体同士の「関係」、たとえば「人が犬を撫でている」とか「コップがテーブルの上にある」といったことを、あらかじめ決められた語彙にしばられず、どんな言葉でもリアルタイムで認識できる小さなエーアイモデル「RelateAnything」を発表した論文です。
これまでなら、巨大なVLM、つまり視覚言語モデル、画像と文章を同時に扱えるエーアイに頼らざるを得なかった領域ですが、この種の問題も、こういった軽量なモデルで解けることを示したという意味で非常に注目されています。
画像から「何が」「何と」「どういう関係にあるか」を取り出す技術は「シーングラフ生成」と呼ばれています。
ロボットや自動運転、画像検索などの基盤となる技術ですが、これまでのモデルは、学習時に50個程度の関係語しか取り扱えず、それ以外の関係は表現できないという弱点がありました。
著者は、この理由として「多様な関係語を含む検証済みデータが存在しないこと」、「学習語彙の外側の言葉を受け付けるモデル構造がないこと」、そして「語彙を広げることで逆に性能が低下する評価方法しかないこと」という三つの点を挙げています。
RelateAnythingは、これら三つの問題を一気に解決するために開発されたものです。
モデルの大きさ、つまりパラメータ数はわずか5300万で、1フレームごとに20ミリ秒で処理することができます。
画像と「物体の場所（領域）」を入力して、推論時にはテキストで与えた任意の関係語彙に対してスコアを出力できます。
これは、物体のラベル、たとえば「犬」や「人」といったタグを入力として必要とせず、どんな物体検出器とも組み合わせできるため、再学習が不要という特徴があります。
さらに、19,103種類もの関係語を使い、たとえば「上」と「下」など反対語もきちんと区別できるテキストエンコーダーで学習されています。
あわせて、47万枚の画像に対して幾何学的に検証済みの430万件、関係語でいえば10,102種類もの関係をつけた学習データ「RA-4M」と、語彙の拡張力を正しく評価するためのベンチマーク「OV-SGG-Bench」も公開されています。
既存のオープン語彙手法と比較して、平均再現率、つまり正解の関係をどれだけ取りこぼさずに見つけられるかの指標で、2.3倍から3.5倍の性能を達成しており、しかもパラメータ数は2パーセント以下ですが、3B（30億）パラメータのVLMを上回った、としています。
モデルもデータもベンチマークも、すべて公開されています。
そして注目すべきなのは、この論文を書いたMaelic Neauさんが、エーアイベンチャーや研究所に属さない独立系の研究者であることです。
LinkedInのプロファイルを見ると、2024年に博士号を取得したばかりのポスドクで、半年ほど日本のNII、国立情報学研究所で働いたことがあるようです。
[EN]OpenAI Acquires Glass Imaging: AI Camera Hardware[/EN]
まず最初に、オープンエーアイが、スマートフォンのカメラ画質をエーアイで高める技術を持つスタートアップ、Glass Imagingを買収したという報道からお伝えします。
買収は、三億ドル、つまり約四百八十億円を超える評価額で行われました。
Glass Imagingは、2019年にジヴ・アターさんとトム・ビショップさんという、二人の元アップルのエンジニアが創業した会社です。
アターさんは、2011年にLinX Imagingという企業を立ち上げ、その後2015年にアップルに買収されました。
さらに、iPhone 7 Plusのポートレートモード、背景をぼかして人物を浮かび上がらせるあの機能ですね、その開発チームを率いていた方なんです。
ビショップさんも、2013年から2018年までアップルでポートレートモードの技術に携わっていました。
Glass Imagingはこれまでにシードとシリーズエーで合計約三千万ドル、円にして約四十八億円を調達してきましたが、今回の買収評価額はその約十倍にあたります。
同社の柱の技術は、GlassAIと呼ばれるニューラルISP、つまり画像信号処理プロセッサです。
これはカメラのセンサーから送られてくる生データを、私たちが目にする写真に変換する部分を指します。
今までのカメラは、ノイズ除去や色補正、シャープ化といった処理を順番にこなすパイプラインで画像を作っていたんですが、GlassAIはそこをまるごとニューラルネットワークに置き換えて、レンズの歪みやセンサーのノイズ、ブレなどを正しつつ、細かい部分を復元する技術なんです。
特徴的なのは、エーアイで「それらしいピクセルを書き足す」のではなく、じっさいに撮影されたデータを処理しているという点です。
しかも、すでにHonorのスマホ「600シリーズ」のズーム撮影機能に採用されていました。
私は前から、見たり聞いたりするものを二十四時間ずっと一緒に把握して、サポートしてくれる「常駐型エーアイアシスタント」の時代が来るだろうと予測しています。
そうしたデバイスにとっては、少ない消費電力でリアルタイムに映像を処理できることが何より大事ということで、今回の買収もその狙いだと考えていいと思います。
また、エルエルエムが画像を解釈する場合には、カメラモジュールから受け取った画像を一度、「潜在空間」つまりラテントスペースのデータに落とし込んでから処理しますが、その役割をカメラモジュールそのものが担えれば、消費電力を大幅に抑えることができるようになります。
ですから今回の買収は、こういった深い技術的な一歩を踏み込むことでこそ意味がある話になるんです。
[EN]Moats & the Barbell-ification of Software[/EN]
続いて、ソフトウェアの「堀」、つまり他社がまねしにくい強みがエーアイ時代にどう変わるのか、という話題です。
元Facebook幹部でベンチャー投資家のMike Vernalさんが書いた記事ですが、ソフトウェアの開発コストがエーアイでほぼゼロになることで、業界の構造が大きく変わる、という指摘です。
ソフトウェア業界が、1990年代の新聞業界のように、「巨大企業」と「個人・小規模事業」に二極化し、中間層が消えてしまう、という主張なんですね。
この話は、「サースビジネスの終わり」説とも重なるものですが、要するにソフトウェアがコモディティ化してしまうことで、ソフトウェアだけで価値を生み出すのが難しくなってくるということです。
インフラまで持ち、長年の顧客との繋がりがあるマイクロソフトやグーグルのような巨大企業は有利ですが、そういったインフラやつながりがないソフトウェア企業が大きな規模のビジネスをするのはますます難しくなる、という話です。
逆に、顧客ごとに必要なソフトウェアをその場で作って提供していくタイプのビジネスは、規模の面では大きくなくても、今後もっと成長する余地があります。
ただし、従来型の人月工数型ではなく、マイクロ・サースのような月額課金スタイルで提供し、それを積み重ねていくのが良いのではないか、と私は感じています。
[EN]Introducing PC-ALM, a local-learning alternative to backpropagation[/EN]
ここからは、エーアイの学習方法についての新たなアプローチをご紹介します。
日本のエーアイスタートアップ、Sakana エーアイが、いま主流のディープラーニング、つまり多層ニューラルネットワークの学習方法であるバックプロパゲーションを使わずに、千層ものニューラルネットワークを学習させる新手法、「PC-ALM」を発表しました、という話題です。
人間の脳のように、「局所的な仕組み」だけで学習するエーアイを作ろうという研究で、まさにエーアイの学習そのものを見直そうという動きです。
ちなみに、バックプロパゲーションとは、ニューラルネットワークの出力と正解のズレ、つまり誤差を、出力側から入力側に向かって全層逆向きに伝え、各層のパラメータを修正する手法のことで、その後のエーアイの発展を支える重要な技術になっています。
ただし、「脳はバックプロパゲーションしない」という話は多くの専門家も指摘していて、人間の脳がしているような、もっと局所的な学習方法を再現できれば、今よりずっと電力効率の良いエーアイができるはずだと考える人もたくさんいます。
今回の「PC-ALM」も、そういった研究の一つです。
Sakana エーアイは、日本のエーアイベンチャーの中でも注目の存在で、たまにこういう面白い論文を出してくる会社なんです。
シーティーオーのリオン・ジョーンズさんは、2017年の論文「Attention Is All You Need」に名を連ねる八人の共著者の一人で、エルエルエムの基盤となるTransformerを考案したチームの一員です。
会社はこれまでに累計で約四億千二百万ドルを調達し、企業価値も二十七億ドルを超える、いわゆるユニコーンの一つになっています。
オープンエーアイやアンソロピックといったフロンティア・ラボが、圧倒的に巨大かつ優秀な「超知性」の開発に競い合う中、Sakana エーアイは全く違う切り口でイノベーションを起こそうとしている点が、とても興味深いと思います。
[EN]MIT Report on AI Use in Teaching, Learning, and Research Training[/EN]
次は、エーアイが教育現場に与える影響についてです。
MITが学内に特別委員会を設けて、「エーアイが大学教育をどう変えてしまったのか、そしてMITはどう対応すべきか」を半年かけて調査したという報告書から、注目すべきポイントをお伝えします。
世界トップの理工系大学が、エーアイによって教育の土台が揺らいでいると率直に認めたことは、大きな意味があります。
この報告書が重要視しているのは、学ぶために必要な「生産的な苦労」をエーアイが取り除いてしまう、という危険性です。
こう言うと説教くさく聞こえるかもしれませんが、若いころの苦労や下積みでしか学べないことが、どの業界でもたくさんあるのは事実です。
でも近年は、学生自身がエーアイを使うことでその苦労を体験せずに成人してしまう現象と、社会に出てから下積みで学ぶチャンス自体がエーアイによって消えつつある現象、この二つが同時進行しているように見えます。
その結果として、「人が育たない社会」ができつつあるように、私は感じています。
エーアイによって社会は大きく発展するかもしれませんが、それは同時に「エーアイに頼らなければ何もできない人類」を生み出しつつあるかもしれません。
[EN]EMS statement on recent Navier-Stokes announcement[/EN]
続いて、エーアイによる数学界の話題です。
オープンエーアイが、「ナビエ・ストークス方程式のミレニアム懸賞問題を解決した」と発表したことを受けて、ヨーロッパ数学会（イーエムエス）が公式声明を発表した、という記事を取りあげます。
エーアイによる数学の大発見を、専門家のコミュニティがどのように受け止めたのかがわかる内容です。
ナビエ・ストークス方程式は、水や空気など流体の動きを表す方程式で、「この方程式は常になめらかな解を持つのか？
」という問いが、百万ドルの賞金がかかる七つの「ミレニアム懸賞問題」の一つとして、長年未解決のままだった課題です。
オープンエーアイは、この問題を社内の数学者とエーアイモデルの共同作業によって解決したと発表しました。
イーエムエスの声明では、まずこの発表を「数学の歴史における一つのマイルストーン」と位置づけています。
その理由として、未解決問題が解けた可能性があるだけでなく、論文がオープンエーアイ名義で発表されている一方で、人間の数学者とエーアイモデルの共同成果であることが明記されている、その「作られ方」にも注目しているんです。
また、この解決はまったくゼロから生まれたわけではなく、ディエゴ・コルドバさん、ルイス・マルティネス＝ゾロアさん、ファン・ジェンさん、この三人の数学者が提案していた戦略に近いものであり、アンソロピックのレーヴェント・アルポージさんやニューヨーク大学のトリスタン・バックマスターさんによる最近の進展、さらに世界中の数学者たちによる数十年にわたる積み重ねの上に成り立っていると強調しています。
2022年にリリースされた当時のChatGPTは、「人間と会話できる」程度のものでしたが、わずか四年で数学の未解決問題を解決できるまでに進化してきました。
エーアイの研究者たちが、「これからはエーアイが科学を進化させる」と予測するのは、まさにこうした進化を現実に目にしているからなのでしょう。
[EN]GPT-6 Astra Masterclass: What Changed, What Broke, and How to Prompt Around It[/EN]
それでは、週刊Life is beautiful、2026年9月22日号をお届けします。
今回は、新手のエーアイ「JEV」、エーアイの危険性、そしてフロンティア・ラボのビジネスモデルについて、パート4/7としてお話ししていきます。
まずは、「ジーピーティー-6 Astra」についてです。
9月3日にリリースされたオープンエーアイの最新モデル「ジーピーティー-6 Astra」について、ベンチマークでどこが良くなったのか、現場で実際に何が壊れているのか、そしてそれをプロンプト、つまりエーアイへの指示文でどうやって回避できるのかをまとめた解説記事がありました。
この解説が貴重なのは、発表直後に話題になる華やかな数字だけじゃなくて、ユーザーが実際ぶつかっている問題をかなり具体的に取り上げているところです。
なので、今回はそれを紹介していきます。
「Astra」の最大の変化は、従来のエージェントのようにいきなりエーピーアイを呼び出すんじゃなくて、人間と同じように画面を見て、カーソルを動かして、クリックして、文字を打ってソフトウェアを操作する点です。
ベンチマークを見てみると、ARC-AGI-3で99.9パーセント、FrontierMathの最難関ティア4で98パーセント、そしてセキュリティ評価のExploitBenchでは前の世代の「ジーピーティー-5.6 Sol」が78.5パーセントだったのに対して100パーセントを記録しています。
実際のPC操作を測るOSWorld 2.0では、Solが65.7パーセント（これには75分かかる）だったのに対して、Astraでは72.6パーセントをだいたい40分で達成できたということです。
実用面で一番大きいのは、エーピーアイの無い社内ツールや古いソフトウェアまで自動化できるようになるっていうところですね。
最近は、アンソロピックがコーディング能力にかなり力を入れている一方で、オープンエーアイはブラウザやアプリの操作に力を入れている、この点は両者の差別化や使い分けという意味ですごく興味深いと感じています。
さっきお伝えした通り、私は「ジーピーティー-6 Astra」の一番の価値は3Dモデルの生成能力だと思っていまして、コーディングの部分に関してはアンソロピックのエーアイモデルとの間で大きな差を感じていません。
[EN]Japan doesn't have a humanoid robot company worth owning but it has the entire parts list[/EN]
続いて、こちらも注目の話題です。
日本には投資対象になるヒューマノイド、つまりひとがたロボットのメーカーはない一方で、ヒューマノイドに必要な部品はほとんど全て日本企業が作っていて、部品メーカーに投資する方がビジネスとして魅力がある、という投資家の投稿を紹介します。
これはGoldman Sachsが作った「ヒューマノイド産業に部品を供給する日本企業の一覧表」に基づいた話です。
この表で特に目立つのが、アクチュエーター、つまりモーターと減速機を組み合わせてロボットの関節を動かす部品のところでして、Denso、Aisin、JTEKT、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズ、NTN、NSK、Nidec、安川電機、ファナック、三菱電機、ミネベアミツミ、以上11社が名を連ねています。
ちなみに、Boston DynamicsのAtlasの場合、部品コストの52パーセントがアクチュエーター、32パーセントがグリッパー（物をつかむ手の部分）が占めていると言われているんですね。
業界全体で見ると、ヒューマノイド部品の売上のおよそ58パーセントをアクチュエーターが占めていて、しかも年率36パーセントで成長しているそうです。
投稿者が一番注目しているのは、ハーモニック・ドライブ・システムズです。
会社の四半期におけるエーアイロボット向けの受注は十二億五千万円と、アナリスト予想の二倍以上となっています。
会社側としては、2026年3月期のヒューマノイド向け受注を二十五億円、翌期にはその二倍から三倍になるかもしれない、と説明しています。
ヒューマノイド一台には25〜50個の関節があって、TeslaのOptimusでは1台に14個のハーモニックドライブ（波動歯車減速機）が使われていると言われています。
これを1個約800ドルとして10万台分計算すると、約十六億ドルの需要になり、これは既存の産業用ロボット向けしじょうの五倍から十倍に当たります。
同社の去年の売上は五百九十五億円ですから、ヒューマノイドが本格的に普及すれば既存事業をはるかに上回る規模になるというわけです。
前にもお伝えしましたが、ひとがたロボットやドローンが必要とする部品や素材を中国に変わって米国を含む西側諸国に提供することが、日本の製造業が今後も維持、発展していくうえで一番筋の通った戦略ではないかと私は考えています。
もちろん、最終製品を全く持たずに部品や素材だけを進化させていくのは簡単なことではありません。
その点を、この記事にも出てくるトヨタ自動車などが業界をリードしてくれることに期待しています。
[EN]Korea's Trillion-Dollar Sovereign AI Investment: Nvidia Wins, Hynix Loses[/EN]
ここからは、韓国による「主権エーアイ」投資についてです。
韓国が国を挙げて推進している「主権エーアイ」、つまり外国に頼らず自国でエーアイモデルとデータセンターを持とうという巨額投資が、最終的には最大の受益者としてエヌビディアが潤い、韓国のメモリメーカーSK Hynixには重荷となる、という分析を半導体専門メディアSemiAnalysisがまとめています。
韓国政府は2025年6月、「独自エーアイファウンデーションモデル（さまざまな用途の土台となる大型のエーアイモデル）」プロジェクトを発表し、応募があった15チームからNaver Cloud、LGエーアイ Research、SK Telecom、NCエーアイ、Upstageの5チームを選定しました。
政府の総予算は約三億五千万ドル、だいたい五百六十億円ですね。
第一ラウンドではエヌビディアのエーアイ用ジーピーユー（H100）に換算して約三千個分の計算資源、データ購入費、研究者の採用費などがそれぞれのチームに分配されます。
六ヶ月ごとに評価をおこなって、負けたチームは脱落、勝ったチームに資源を集中させる勝ち抜き戦の形式となっています。
評価はベンチマーク、つまり標準テストの成績が40パーセント、専門家評価が35パーセント、ユーザーテストが25パーセントという割り振りです。
記事が問題視しているのは、この選抜からMotif Technologiesが外された点です。
Motifは従業員三十人未満、資金調達は千七百万ドルという小さな会社ながら、エヌビディアの最新世代ジーピーユーであるB200を768個使わない範囲、費用も千五百万ドルで訓練した「Motif 3」は、中国系以外のオープンソースモデルとしては最高水準だと評価されています。
それだけの成果を出した会社が不透明な基準で脱落させられたのは、韓国のエーアイ人材流出リスクにつながる、と記事は指摘しています。
いっぽうで、データセンター側の計画は規模が桁違いです。
・2029年までに8.4ギガワット、2035年までに18.4ギガワットのエーアイデータセンターを建設
・総投資額は九千百九十億ドル、つまり約百四十七兆円
[EN]第1段階の内訳はSK Groupが5GW、GS Groupが2.4GW、Naverが1GW[/EN]
また、SK Telecomの2ギガワット規模の「エーアイファクトリー」にはエヌビディアの次世代システム「Vera Rubin」を導入予定です。
Samsungも五万個以上のジーピーユーを使ったエーアイファクトリーを建設する予定です。
エヌビディアは韓国側と五千億ドル、約八十兆円規模の覚書、つまり正式契約の前段階の合意を発表しています。
要するに、韓国が「主権エーアイ」のもとに投じるお金の大半は、エヌビディア製ジーピーユーの購入に充てられることになります。
エヌビディアにとっては、アンソロピックとオープンエーアイという二大顧客への依存を軽減できる、戦略的にも非常に重要なしじょうになります。
さらに、エヌビディアはSK Hynixから有利な価格でのHBM、つまりジーピーユー用高帯域メモリの長期契約と2027年分の大量供給の約束を引き出した可能性が高い、と記事は見ています。
ちなみに、日本政府もエーアイ戦略に大きな投資を行うと宣言していますが、同じような状況に陥る可能性も高いので注意が必要です。
前にもメルマガで触れましたが、各国政府が独自のエーアイインフラ、つまりソブリンエーアイを育てる取り組み自体が、エヌビディアにとって大きな追い風となる、これはまさにエヌビディアが思い描いたとおりの展開になってきているということです。
続いて、エーアイだけで作ったアプリが公開から三日で百五十万件もの情報漏洩を起こしてしまった、という事件についてです。
そして、そうならないために気をつけるべきポイントを5つまとめた内容になっています。
エーアイツールの内製支援やセキュリティチェックを専門としている八木利生太郎さんが、今年1月に起きた「Moltbook」の情報漏洩事件を題材に、ばいぶコーディングで作ったアプリで起こりがちなセキュリティの穴と、それを防ぐための5つのポイントを解説してくれています。
くわしい内容は日本語の記事を読んでもらうのが一番ですが、ばいぶコーディングで作ったアプリというのは、いわば手作りの飛行機のようなもので、たしかに空は飛べても、安全性はまったく保証されていない、そう認識しておく必要があります。
うっかり世界最強のWasmコンパイラを作ってしまった話
ここでは、Goによく似た書きやすい文法を持ちつつ、ランタイム、つまり実行時に必ず同梱される土台部分をほぼゼロにできることで、極端に小さいWasm、つまりWebAssemblyのバイナリを生成する自作プログラミング言語「Hike」のコンパイラを個人で作ったという記事を紹介します。
ブラウザ向けにWasmを“気軽に”使える道を開拓したことがとても興味深かったので取り上げています。
Wasmは非常に高速ですが、実際にフロントエンド開発で使おうとすると、生成されるバイナリが大きくなりがちです。
そのバイナリの大きさには、もちろん自分が書いたプログラムの量も影響しますが、それ以上に効いてくるのが、どんなに短いプログラムでも必ずくっついてくる「固定費」の部分なんですね。
標準のGoでコンパイルすると、ガーベージコレクション、
使い終わったメモリを自動で回収する仕組みや、スケジューラが最初からすべて含まれているため、著者が試した「文字列のスライス処理」や「DOMの書き換え」、「再帰によるフィボナッチ計算」などの小さなサンプルプログラムでも、サイズが二・五から三メガバイトになってしまい、ちょっとしたフォームの検証などで読み込むには明らかに重すぎるんです。
これに対して、組み込み向けのTinyGoなら三十から百キロバイト、Rustなら五から二十キロバイトに収めることができますが、Rustは学習コストの高さが壁になっています。
Hikeで同じサンプルをコンパイルすると、わずか二・五六キロバイトだったということです。
実際に試したわけではありませんが、言語やコンパイラが好きな私にとっては、本当にワクワクする話で、Game80コンパイラを作った頃を思い出してしまいました。
ここからは、質問コーナーについてです。
まず、一つ目の質問です。
堀江貴文さんのメルマガに、次のような内容が含まれていましたので、一部抜粋します。
生成エーアイ「Claude」を開発するAnthropic。
先日、作家たちとの著作権裁判で約二千四百億円という巨額の和解が成立したばかりですが、その過程で公開された大量の裁判資料から明らかになった事実があります。
まず、この裁判で問題とされたのは、海賊版サイトから大量の本のデータを集めていた点です。
また、ソニー系の音楽出版社など三十五社が、歌詞を無断で学習させたとしてAnthropicを訴えており、その裁判の行方や和解が注目されています。
ここで質問です。
「本や歌詞、メロディなど、人間が積み上げてきたものを学習用データとして有料で提供するビジネスは成立するでしょうか？
もし成立するなら、作者や作曲者の価値は今後どのように変わるとお考えですか？
」
これに対する回答です。
大量のデータを著作権をクリアにした上でエーアイラボが扱いやすい形に整理して提供するのであれば、良いビジネスになると思います。
こうした学習用データの整備をビジネスにしている代表例がScaleエーアイで、画像や文章へのラベル付け、人間によるフィードバックデータ、つまりRLHF用のデータの作成や、モデルの評価などを大手エーアイラボ向けに請け負い、二千二十五年六月にはMetaから百四十三億ドル、つまり二兆円超を受け取って、実質的に買収されました。
著作物そのもののライセンスという意味だと、RedditやNews Corpがエーアイラボと結んだ契約や、今回のAnthropicの和解（一冊あたり約三千ドル）が「対価を払えば使える」といった新しい相場を作りつつあります。
作者や作曲者の価値については、人間の読者や聴衆に向けた本来の市場で決まるという構造は変わらないと思います。
ここにエーアイ向けのライセンス収入という第二の収益源が加わることになりますが、一作品あたりの単価は、先ほどの和解金額が示すように、作者が期待するほど大きなものにはならないでしょう。
むしろこれからは、エーアイが大量にコンテンツを生み出す時代になるので、「この人が作った」というブランドや、ファンとの直接の繋がりを持つ作者の価値が、相対的に上がっていくと考えています。
続いて、二つ目の質問です。
以前から私が、UIEvolution、現在のXevoでトヨタと仕事をしていた経験を踏まえて、「トヨタはソフトウェアを外注し、車載器メーカーやその下請けに仕様書を渡す形で開発してきた」と書いていたことが印象に残っているという内容でした。
最近、酒井崇男さんの動画をきっかけに、トヨタのChief Engineer制度や製品開発について調べている中で、少し疑問が生まれたそうです。
酒井さんの説明では、Chief Engineerが顧客に提供する価値を考え、それを車両全体の機能へ落とし込む中で各部門を統合し、製品を成立させているとのこと。
初代プリウスなどを見ると、エンジン、モーター、バッテリーなどの高度な協調制御もトヨタ自身が深く開発していて、単純に「ソフトウェアを作れない会社」とも思えなくなったそうです。
そこで伺いたいのですが、中島さんが「トヨタはソフトウェアが弱い」と指摘していたのは、主にUIEvolution時代に関わったナビやコネクテッド、車載ユーアイなどの領域を指していたのでしょうか。
つまり、トヨタは車両制御のような「クルマを成立させるソフトウェア」には強い内製能力を持つ一方で、ユーザーが直接触れるソフトウェアを一つの製品として作り、ユーザーインターフェースやユーザーエクスペリエンスを継続的に改善していく能力が弱かった、という理解で良いのでしょうか。
また、そうだとすれば、トヨタにはChief Engineerを中心に商品価値を統合する強い製品開発の仕組みがあるのに、なぜナビや車載ユーアイ、コネクテッドの分野ではその強さを十分に発揮できなかったのでしょうか。
当時は、こうした領域が走りや燃費、品質などと同じレベルの重要な商品価値として、Chief Engineerを中心とした製品企画の中に十分組み込まれていなかったのでしょうか。
UIEvolutionを通じてトヨタと実際に仕事をしていた中島さんから見て、この整理がどのくらい実態に近いのか、お聞きしたいです。
参考までに、今回この疑問を持つきっかけになった酒井崇男さんの記事と動画の紹介もありました。
この質問への回答です。
ご指摘の整理は、ほぼ実態に近いと考えます。
私から見て、トヨタ自動車の問題は大きく分けて二つありました。
一つ目は、車載器、つまりカーナビを搭載するコンピュータを外部から調達する部品として扱う開発体制そのものにあります。
カーナビや運転補助、エンターテイメント、スマートフォンとの接続などは、自動車を運転するユーザーの体験としてますます重要になっていますが、それでもカーナビがまだオプションだった頃の発想でものづくりをしていました。
そのため、たとえばスピードメーターなどが表示されているダッシュボードとの一体感もなく、これは別々の会社が作っていたからなんですが、ユーザー体験自体の優先順位も「運転のし心地」や「乗り心地」などと比べると、かなり低かったのです。
二つ目は、現場で働くエンジニアたちのマインドセットを経営陣がまったく理解していなかったことです。
副社長クラスの人とインセンティブについて話をしたとき、私がストックオプションの話を出したのですが、全然理解してもらえませんでした。
日本の大企業しか経験のない人たちが、ソフトウェアベンチャーで働くエンジニアにとってストックオプションの存在がどれほど重要かを理解するのはなかなか難しいですが、副社長クラスの人がそのあたりを一切勉強していなかったことには、私もショックを受けました。
これは二千十九年ごろの話なので、今は少し改善しているかもしれませんが、この二つはいずれも「企業カルチャー」そのものに根ざしたもので、簡単には変わらないと思います。
続いて、三つ目の質問です。
エヌビディアのジェンスン・フアン氏がオープンエーアイによるエージーアイ達成を祝福し、他の専門家からも同様の声が上がっていますが、本当にエージーアイ、つまり汎用人工知能は実現したのでしょうか？
また、今後、もしもどこか一社が最初にエーエスアイ、つまり人工超知能を実現し、それをしばらく独占し続けた場合、他の会社と圧倒的な差がついて、市場や技術のすべてを獲得し、「圧勝」するのではないかと思うのですが、この点について中島先生の見解をお聞かせください。
これに対する回答です。
エージーアイもエーエスアイも定義が曖昧なので、「エージーアイが実現したか？
」というより、「エージーアイと呼ぶに値するほど進化したか？
」で考えたほうが良いと思います。
ジェンスン・フアン氏は、Astraにはそれだけの価値があると認めたということです。
もしどこか一社がエーエスアイと呼べる人工知能を実現し、他社が全く追いつけないとしたら、それは大きな差別化につながり、他社を圧倒するどころか、世界の覇権を握る可能性すら出てきます。
しかし、今の状況を見る限り、先端を走り続けるのは数社である可能性が高いと思います。
また、そうなった時代には、単にモデル同士の競争だけではなく、インフラの力、つまり総計算量をどれだけ持っているかという戦いにもなってくるので、その点も意識しておくと良いと思います。
さて、次の質問です。
最近、エーアイの普及によって既存産業のコスト構造や利益率そのものが大きく変わる可能性に興味を持っている、という質問です。
たとえば、Minerva Intelligenceという企業が「会計事務所を買収し、業務をエーアイネイティブに作り直すことで営業利益率を五パーセントから七十パーセントまで改善した」と発信していました。
もちろん、この数字自体の持続可能性については別として、エーアイ企業をゼロから作るのではなく、すでに顧客や売上がある既存企業にエーアイを導入することで、人間はより付加価値の高い仕事に集中し、企業全体の生産性や利益率を大きく引き上げるという考え方は、中島さんが以前から話していることにも近いと感じました。
投資家の視点で見ると、こうした「エーアイによって既存のコスト構造や利益率が大きく変わる企業」は、今後非常に面白い投資対象になるのではと思うのですが、中島さんが今、こうした観点で具体的に注目している企業や業界はありますか？
また、すでにエーアイによる生産性向上が業績に現れ始めている企業があれば、ぜひ教えていただきたいです。
この質問への回答です。
具体的に注目している企業は特にありませんが、このケースのように、既存の会社が自力で変化するのではなく、企業買収のような形で生まれ変わっていくほうが現実的だと思います。
その場合は、買収される会社の株ではなく、買収する側の株を持っておくのが良いと思います。
さらに、次の質問です。
Rivianのシーイーオー、RJ Scaringeについてどのような印象を持っていますか？
イーロン・マスクやスティーブ・ジョブズが持っていたようなカリスマ性を感じますか？
この質問への回答は…
では、まず最初に、ジェンスン・フアンさんについてですが、彼はエヌビディアの素晴らしい経営者です。
でも、個人的にはイーロン・マスクさんのような圧倒的なカリスマ性はそれほど感じません。
ただ、イーロン・マスクさんに匹敵するほどのカリスマ性を持つ人自体がそもそも珍しい存在なので、そこを特にマイナスに考える必要もないかなと思います。
ここからはエーアイの遊び心と実験についてのご質問にお答えします。
イノベーションについてですが、過去には研究者の遊び心や「失敗」から画期的な発見が数多く生まれてきた、というご指摘がありました。
たとえば、島津製作所の田中さんがノーベル賞を取ったエピソードなどがその良い例ですね。
最近では、エーアイを活用して自動で実験が進んでいく環境の中で、新しい薬や素材の研究が進められています。
では、その実験に意図的な失敗やユーモアの要素など、いわゆる「遊び心」を加えることができるのか、というご質問です。
私はエーアイに「遊び心」があるとは思いません。
ただし、エーアイはパラメータを少しずつ変えながら膨大な組み合わせを試していくのがとくいなので、そうしたプロセスの中から新しい発見にたどり着く可能性は高いと思います。
数学の分野でエーアイの発見が先行しているのは、なによりもデジタルの世界の中だけですべての実験・検証ができてしまうからなんです。
ですが、今後は現実の実験装置とエーアイがどんどんつながっていくので、化学や医療分野でも新しい発見や発明のスピードがいっそう加速するのではないかと、私は期待しています。
続いて、データレイクハウスとAIモデルの入れ替えについてのご質問ですね。
エーアイを前提とした社内のデータレイクハウス、たとえばBigQueryを想定したシステムと、その上で動くMA・SFA・CRMなどを、自社でエーアイを使って開発するプロジェクト。
裏側のエーアイモデルがどんどん進化することに対応するため、柔軟に切り替えられる構成にしたい、というご相談です。
その中でOpenRouterの本番組み込みを検討したものの、開発現場から
・データ保持期間の問題（直契約なら即時削除できるが、OpenRouterは三十日固定で変えられない）
・DPA（いわゆるデータ利用に関する制限契約）が不透明で、結べないと監督義務違反になるリスクがある
・監査ログの問題（OpenRouter経由だとログが見られない）
この三つの懸念が挙げられた、と。
なので「検証フェーズではOpenRouterでよいが、本番では各モデルと直接契約がよい」という意見も出ているそうです。
その場合、中国製の安価なモデルは直契約が難しいので本番では諦めざるを得ないかもしれないが、それも片手落ちで悩ましい、ということですね。
ご相談の前提は、「売上が百億円程度、従業員が百名ほどのB to B中心のIT企業」で、BigQueryを想定した規模感です。
これについてですが、三つの懸念点はどれもごもっともで、やはり直契約にすればこれらの課題はクリアできます。
ソフトウェアをしっかり作ってあればモデルの切り替え自体はそれほど難しくないと思いますので、OpenRouterは使わず、社内で作ったモジュールを使って、モデルの入れ替えに対応するのがよいと思います。
さらに、社内サーバーでオープンウェイトなモデルも動かせるようにしておくと、将来的に「機密データをエーアイサービスに出すわけにはいかない」となった場合でも、すぐにそちらへ切り替えられるので安心です。
中国製モデルの多くはオープンウェイトですので、この方法なら社内で安全に利用できます。
続いて、ロボタクシーと日本のタクシー業界についてのご質問です。
「GO」「Waymo」「日本交通」が二千二十七年中に東京で無人ロボタクシーの商用化を目指す、というニュースの件ですね。
なぜ日本ではタクシー会社が間に入るのかという疑問や、「ロボタクシーによって一割ぐらいの料金でタクシー移動ができるようになるんじゃないか」と期待したのに、Waymoが直接サービスに乗り出さなければ、「ロボタクシーには乗れても、今と料金が変わらない」ということになってしまうのでは、と危惧されているんですね。
私の考えとしては、Uberの日本進出の事例を見ても分かる通り、日本社会はこの種のビジネス変化にかなり保守的です。
そして、どこか社会主義的な調整が働きやすいんです。
まずはタクシー会社が自動運転車を運行する、というスタートの仕方はすごく日本的で、「これだと自動運転になっても料金は下がらない」という懸念はその通りだと思います。
ちなみに、私が前回出張で羽田空港までUberを利用した時、テスラのModel Yで迎えにきてくれて、しかもタクシーと同じ都内からの定額運賃が適用されて、とても満足しました。
最近は台数も増えていて、ようやくUberも市民権を得てきたんじゃないかなと感じています。
自動運転車についても導入には時間がかかると思いますが、最終的には日本社会の中できちんと受け入れられると思います。
ドライバー不足や高齢化が日本最大の課題なので、たとえ値段が下がらなくても、自動運転車には十分な価値があるはずです。
次は、エーアイによる新規需要と投資先の探し方についてのご相談ですね。
エーアイの本質的なインパクトは、単に既存業務の効率化ではなく、今までになかったアプリやサービス、そして新しい需要が生まれることにある。
たとえば、エーアイによって個人でも自分専用アプリをサクッと作れるようになる、これはまさにその一例というご意見です。
でも、そこからさらに投資先や具体的な着眼点を探す段階で、「どんな情報源や人物を参考にすれば良いか分からない」とのお悩みですね。
私自身がよく参考にしているものをご紹介します。
Podcastで言えば、「All-in Podcast」がオススメです。
注目している人物としては、最近はGavin BakerさんやDylan Patelさんの発言に目を向けています。
ベンチャーキャピタルで有益な情報を発信しているのは「a16z」です。
続いて、半導体製造装置最大手のApplied Materials、通称AMATへの投資タイミングについてのご質問です。
お手元のドル資金に余裕があるため、オルカン、いわゆる全世界株式型のポートフォリオを中核にしつつ、半導体製造装置最大手のApplied Materials（AMAT）をサテライト投資として組み込もうか検討中とのこと。
その理由としては、エーアイという現代のゴールドラッシュの中で、AMATは金を掘るプレイヤーではなく、「最先端のツルハシ＝半導体装置」を独占的に供給する元売りだと考えたから、ということですね。
ただし、「どのタイミングで買うか」は非常に悩ましい、というご質問です。
どんな指標を参考にするか、アドバイスがほしいという内容です。
私自身はApplied Materialsの株は持ってはいませんが、とても素晴らしい会社だと思っています。
買うタイミングを見極めるのはとても難しいので、私の場合は気に入った会社があれば思いついた時に少しずつ株を買い始めて、その後「これは自分事だな」と感じられるようになったら、ドルコスト平均法で数か月にわたって段階的に買い増していく、という方式をとっています。
ここからはエーアイ普及後の経済構造と投資戦略についてです。
[EN]Anthropicが先日公開した「Scenarios for our Economic Future」を読みました。
[/EN]
この記事の中では、エーアイの普及によってジーディーピーそのものが大きく成長する可能性があるいっぽう、その成長による富の分配先が「労働」から「資本」へと移っていく可能性がある、という内容が指摘されています。
その話を受けて、今のはいぱーすけーらーたちが巨額のAIインフラ投資を進めているのも同じ文脈に見えてくる、と感じました。
これまで企業が事業規模を拡大するためには「人」を雇って生産能力を高めることが重要でした。
でも今後エーアイ時代には、データセンターや半導体、電力などAIインフラに投資することで、より大きな生産余力を獲得できるようになります。
投資家の立場で言えば、アマゾンやグーグル、マイクロソフト、メタなど「エーアイ時代の生産設備」を大量に保有するはいぱーすけーらーの株を持つことも、この大きな潮流に乗る一つの方法なのでは？
というご意見ですね。
「もし中島さんがAnthropicの示すような、エーアイによって労働から資本へリターンが移っていく世界」になると考えるなら、投資家はどんな戦略やポートフォリオの方向性を取るべきか、というご質問です。
「はいぱーすけーらーの株を持つのが良いのか、それともエヌビディアのような半導体メーカーや、電力・データセンター・ネットワークなどのインフラ・プロバイダーを持つのが良いのか」といった悩みもあるとのこと。
私の考えですが、一番素直に考えれば、やはりマイクロソフト、グーグル、アマゾンなどのはいぱーすけーらーが最も堅いでしょう。
その次にエヌビディア、AMD、Broadcom、ASML、TSMCといった企業が続きます。
私はこれら全ての企業の株を長期保有していて、ポートフォリオの中でも大きな比重を占めています。
引き続き、半導体関連株のリスクについてのご質問です。
ここ最近、半導体関連株はとても高い注目を集めています。
エーアイが進化していくにつれて、半導体じゅようは今後もどんどん拡大していくだろうと見られています。
特にエーアイ関連では、これからもデータセンターやジーピーユーへの投資が続くことで、半導体関連企業の業績や株価も引き続き上昇するだろうと考える方が多いのは確かです。
ただし、質問者さんは少し違ったリスクにも目を向けておられます。
中国の半導体企業も、ここ数年でかなり技術力を高めています。
最先端半導体はともかく、汎用的な半導体やメモリについては、中国国内での生産能力がどんどん向上しているので、今後はその影響で価格が下がることも考えられるのではないか、という懸念です。
特に、中国の半導体自給率が高くなった場合にどういう影響が出るかを気にされているんですね。
たとえば、サムスンやSK hynixなどのメモリメーカーは中国向けの販売比率がかなり高い中で、中国が政策的にメモリの国産化を進めて、これまで海外から輸入していた汎用メモリを自国企業でまかなえるようになれば、世界的なメモリのじゅようや価格形成にも大きな影響が出てくるのではないか、というご指摘です。
ここからは、エーアイ用の最先端メモリ、たとえばHBMなどのじゅようが引き続き強いとしても、汎用メモリの価格が下落することで、サムスンやエスケー・ハイニックスといった企業の業績や株価には下押しの圧力がかかる可能性があるのでは、という話です。
つまり、「エーアイの発展によって半導体じゅようが拡大している」という大きな流れがあるいっぽうで、「中国の半導体自給率が高まることで、最先端以外の半導体やメモリが供給過剰になって価格が下落する」という、逆方向の力も働いているのではないか。
これが私の考えているポイントです。
この点について、中島さんはどう思われますか？
続いて、中島さんからの回答です。
中国に関しては、政治も絡んでくるので先のことを予測するのはとても難しいと感じています。
少し前に、アップルが中国のメーカーからメモリを購入する許可をアメリカ政府に求めたんですが、これもまだ決着がついていません。
この問題の行方次第ではメモリ関連株の株価が大きく動く可能性があると思いますが、それを見越して投資するというのは、私の投資スタイルには合わないんです。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。